Utopianism.
Utopianism is the ism of utopias.
It means a belief or interest
in a perfect world -
or at least a world
designed to be perfect.
The word 'utopia' was coined in 1516
by Sir Thomas More -
writer, saint and opponent
of Henry the VIII's marriage plans -
in his book of the same name.
Utopia has been taken
by some people at face value
as a book about a perfect land.
But others point to the fact that
the word 'utopia' literally means...
and that the book is a satire.
But that hasn’t stopped people.
Through the years
there has been all sorts of ideas
about a perfect society.
Economic utopias with no poverty...
ecological utopias where humans
live in harmony with nature
and so on and so forth.
Many cultures and religions
have a myth
of a perfect society in the past,
like the Garden of Eden.
Communes, music festivals
and naturist camps
could all be seen as attempts
to create a mini utopia on Earth.
There are many kinds of utopias
but one of the central qualities
of any utopia, paradoxically,
is that it doesn’t exist.
Being a utopianist
essentially means being a dreamer.
When John Lennon sang,
"You may say I'm a dreamer"
in his famous hit single
and utopian anthem, Imagine,
he was referring
to exactly this quality.
Utopianism's main flaw
is its obsession with perfection.
This can lead to absurdities
like the Soviet Russian belief
that one day all crime
would be eradicated
because under true socialism
crime would not be necessary.
Or the more sinister belief
in fascist ideologies
that racial purity would
eliminate all evil from society.
Perhaps this is why
much discussion of the topic
is now confined
to utopianism's dark side -
dystopianism,
a way of describing worlds,
real or imaginary,
in entirely negative terms.
From George Orwell's 1984 to
Margaret Atwood's A Handmaid's Tale,
dystopian fiction has become
increasingly popular in books,
films and television.
But interest in utopias
isn't going anywhere -
references within books have been
on a steady rise since the 1900s
with clear spikes in the 60s
and also - perhaps surprisingly -
in the 80s.
And who could deny the perfection of
the world - at least in microcosm -
as you sit by an ocean
and listen to the sound of the waves
crashing on a beach.
Or when you first see a blanket
of bluebells in the spring.
And without at least striving for
a better world, where would we be?
In chains,
with rats chewing off our faces,
that's where.
Thanks for watching! :)
Don’t forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos.